foreign
thanks for joining me on this adventure
my name is Mary and I've played a few
scary games here and there I got to play
through the PT demo before and
a few other awesome games uh Five Nights
at Freddy's and tonight today we're
gonna try The Evil Within uh I kind of
caught a glimpse of this in Japan
I believe
calling it psycho break over there but I
never got to play it so this will be the
first time that I have Hands-On in this
game I think I'm going to play through
it from the very beginning from the very
opening cut scenes and just kind of try
to get a feel for it and we'll see how
far I get
um
there's really no limit to how long I'll
just keep playing it until
um
I'm too scared or we just want to do
something else for a while so
um I will be starting a new game I
haven't besides testing it out and
making sure that it works and everything
I haven't played this so this will be
really cool to
to see for the first time so if you guys
have suggestions for me feel free to
yell them at me in the chat or just tell
me that I'm doing it wrong that's cool
too but let's
let's try it together so I'm gonna start
a new game
and we'll just kind of we'll get going
here we go
it will be
I'll lose everything
um
we'll keep it a little dark it's a
little scarier in the dark I think we
can all agree
and uh let's see standard difficulty
that makes more sense for the weak and
fearful is casual mode we'll do survival
it looks like there's only two out of
three skulls so it seems to me like if
you
played through it all the way then
you'll probably let you do like insane
mode so we'll just do survival
melee attacks can intimidate opponents
well they intimidate me too
I'm a cop
24 copy code three ETA three minutes one
day to retirement
sorry detectives I know you're just
coming off a case but I'm afraid we're
gonna have to make a detour
sounds serious is it a riot call one out
just before I picked you up said it was
multiple homicides half a dozen units
already on scene
he beats the ghost of that doctor who
went schizo and chopped up all those
patients that's not what happened some
patience disappeared
some kind of Scandal
still gives you the creeps doesn't it
speculating you think there's a
connection job is to it's a possibility
I believe the records were sealed
it's a rainy day
what's the situation the most horror
movies
is there any
well my controller is vibrating
all right
looks like there's some interference
Junior detective Kidman any thoughts
nothing yet
I'm sure we'll know everything as we get
there
the ice Department
Asylum
what do you make of it
Godly contact dispatch and let them know
what's happening Joseph Kidman you're
with me nobody has an umbrella oh look
at the rain
thank you
all right here we go
well my range of movement is that I
can't do anything but run
and look around can't jump or anything
yet
what are you investigating it's in there
it's got tinted windows left in their
cars
oh my he's a ghost he went right through
me
just peeping no blood or shell casings
out here
it's a shame when it rains
it's pretty difficult to
gather any evidence
it's a little wet
you waiting on me all right I'll go
first
oh
it smells like blood
all right stay Sharp
felt like
we're gonna check it out don't let
anyone else through this door I can be
an extra set of eyes we don't know
what's happening here
you're a backup
and she's gone
that guy's dead
it's like everybody's super dead
hello sir
looks like I have a little bit of chat
up and running
so if you guys
yell at me I should be able to see it
and it's really possible I haven't seen
I've been avoiding gameplay of other
people playing this game so that I
wouldn't
oh he fell
yeah
I've been avoiding gameplay so that I
would be you know surprised when stuff
happens
um
foreign
so I'll be just as surprised as you guys
when something weird happens but it also
means that there's a really good chance
that at some point I might get stuck and
um I'll have to have you guys help me
out so I'll just we'll work on I heard
there's puzzles in addition to combat
and then just overall you're supposed to
be sneakier the trailer makes it look
like this is more meant to be a sneaky
sleuthing type game not
not so much aggressive
can we go in here
are you injured what happened here what
happened here
can't be real
impossible
I've got him
the security cameras might tell us
something
sounds like an evil guy name if I ever
heard one
is there blood in that coffee
spilled all that blood out
to the security
oh no those cops are so dead
what the hell
it's ruvic
oh no
ew
trying to move
I'm hanging
oh
I really want to look okay there we go
here we go
chopping up something I can't see over
there though won't let me go that far
it's over here
holy
axing somebody
can I see my little [__]
oh
gross
and they all swing to that knife
kind of reminds me of Tomb Raider it's
kind of how the Tomb Raider one started
upside down and swinging
she landed on a like a spike it went
through her gut it's gross come on grab
it
I don't know
well I didn't land on a spike it's good
oh I still hurt my side though
okay
a little Crouch button now
nothing else
there's no like attack button
which would be pretty nice
locked shut well
that's
expected
that's right go away
I appreciate
that he likes good classical music
uh
I think I could just stay snuck here
nope
okay
I'm dead
oh
let me sliced my head off
sliced me good
sliced me up good
all right
I think
I think I need to be sneakier
a little
the feet a little faster too it looks
like
the game said
that they won't notice me if I'm behind
them
a key ring found in the mental hospital
basement these were in use long before
the hospital's modern security system
was put in
GTFO
see look at that super fast walk cycle
he's already back do you think he'll
notice that the keys are gone I should
probably go
he might not appreciate what I just did
it's like he doesn't see me
wait
that's where I just was where is he
you know he's like gonna drop from the
ceiling
or some [__]
that's exactly what's gonna happen
all right let's make it
just hurry up go
[__]
I agree [__]
playing wall
open open opening run run run run oh
there's no sprint button
oh God damn it Ron
spooky
ew oh this is totally again like two
meters
bet you can't hit this thing's super
gross
spiked in the dome
I'm like in bile
my Cut's gonna get infected
look at that it's like a whole human
push him
all right let's get out of here
how is he climbing loose he's got like
one leg
I gotta give him credit for that
checkpoint
I guess that cross means
saving
some noise
feel like
sometimes when noises like that occur
it's a warning for you to be more active
and to like hurry up
but it makes me stop and look around
bunch of dead things
like that
you see that hand
let's see yeah someone said it was kind
of like The Descent I totally see that
too
like that part where she's like halfway
in the blood she's like peeping out
the blood face so gross
oh
I found
nothing
is there anything in here
I can't interact with anything
looks like a giant can opener
there's nothing in here
it's weird why would you want me to go
into a room
behind the locked gate at the far end of
the sewer there is a ladder which would
take you to the old Ward if you could
make it through there it would find an
elevator you would find an elevator
leading outside you would be the one who
escaped you might be the one who
survived are
must be that same guy his name Reuben
evil guy did he move
hey
okay like I said
all right
no
nobody wants me to go through there
either
will my keys unlock this
no okay probably come back to that
there's some over here
same thing
hooray Lottery
I want to watch how crap I am at
climbing those
I have like
barely
my legs like hanging on
it's like
dangling there
and I have to climb this giant ladder
I'm almost there though
Boiler Room note stem system operation
test begins success
confirmation of brain wave
synchronization losses minimal
continuing experiment agent collects
data
anomaly
not with the subject
stenographer claimed they weren't
feeling well and fell into a coma
the doctor orders the stem system
terminated staff begin complaining of
nausea and falling unconscious one after
another
those who can still move plan their
escape from the hospital but for unknown
reasons are unable to through the stem
system we should have
though the stem system should have been
deactivated subjects maintain Brave wave
synchronization with the host
he dot dot dot that man up here it's
that Reuben ruvio
Guy what's that evil dude
check circuit
let me push that fire alarm
checkpoint
which could also mean
shit's about to go down
the lighting looks pretty good in here
I think it does a fairly good job of
telling me where it wants me to go I
mean there's nowhere else to go in that
situation but
the lighting certainly helps guide me
okay that's where I came from
I'll go in here
oh balls
oh my God
oh great bumper get in there you can get
in there you idiot
ooh right bumper to exit
kind of weird
but we all know what will happen
he'll just
oh there he is
think you can hear me
I can hear him he's loud
taking out all the boxes around me
oh
okay it's saved
that's good
I can still hear him though
is it safe to come out
all right here we go
Escape
success oh
oh crap
oh my effing God
bottle a
he's so angry at life
so before I know
where to trick him oh
oh [__] I need to know where the hell to
go
like where the [__] am I going
I can't get through there it's great
where is he
I don't know where he is
oh area
he's so angry
run
all right
oh boy
he sure his [__] found me
foreign
all right
it would appear as if I need to throw
more bottles
oh man he sawed me up good
and like to this
point in the game
I hope you can't see me
I haven't been able to lift like
anything I don't think that bottle is
meant for anything besides to distract I
don't think I'm meant to even try to
hurt him
I just don't think I could win this
is he wearing a like a wife beater
does he have like a farmer tan
angry
all right
I mean he's already where I want him to
be which is not looking at me
hi you idiot all right here we go
that should distract him for
where is he
so here he comes back
and this is how I think he got me again
because I wasn't
item animated
animations I gotta really distract him
[__] oh he saw me I'm [__] at hiding
oh
crap
that's so gross
I'm super dead
I know they're gonna be distracted
throwing bottles
all right
just be a little sneakier
I'm not I'm not very fast that's a
problem as well I wish I was just a
smidge faster
I'm so glimpy
that piece in my leg he cut off
easy
now
such an angry dude
I get the other bottle
[__] damn it keeps Finding Me
Rose
yeah I do think
this could go better
all right this is the one
I think I need to be a little bit more
patient
we are seeing all the death animations
which are pretty interesting
but it's like
right here
like I shouldn't be peeping too much
because he's just gonna catch me
he's so gross
all right
okay
so if he says [__]
I know he's going to catch me oh there's
a little hole in the wall here
go go go
sneak
when you're being sneaky you have to
know the ABCs of sneaking
and it's always be crouching
you crouch that [__] oh
dead
oh man my heart's racing I really don't
want to do that part again
oh God
I can hear him
crawl bastard
go go go
checkpoint all right
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
there's no spring button and I have half
a leg just run
oh no
I feel like I'm in a horror movie
she's tripping over everything
jerk
foreign
I did it
I did it oh
what did I just throw
oh is my
um
oh this is the intro
so that's the opening
to Evil Within
it's pretty good I
I'd really like to see
what combat will be like
um
but I mean from the intro alone it just
kind of confirms what I already thought
which was that
this game is going to be primarily
sneaking around
I probably will have like no ammo it'll
give me like three bullets
and I think that and
the games that have been successful and
scaring me the most
um I would say Amnesia the darkness
descent is probably the scariest game I
ever played and
there is no combat
and it just makes you really helpless
and
afraid and maybe that's what they want
to invoke
in this game but
with a combat system so maybe you can
protect yourself
a little bit
I am out of here
what
I beat the game
oh
my God
Oh I thought that was like a dead person
really I'm sorry but he never came out
I'd waited but good
settle down last night
easy Leslie
we got bigger [__] on our hands
it's like that scene from The Day After
Tomorrow
poor Leslie
you can make it
what a nice little path
how convenient
what do you guys think so far do you
like it
and let them Armageddon in it
I'll close your eyes
driving
those platonic shifts
San Francisco felt like that sometimes
always shifting around easy Leslie
everyone all right back there just a few
bumps we're fine
we once we're far away fine
a little further and we'll be fine
oh
fine
the call is coming from the back of them
did he put his seatbelt on
I remember doing it
yeah it did it
I'll save you
save you in this new slot
all right so I did it
the next chapter
yeah it's like Leslie knew
if you can't pick up any more ammo
reload will allow you to pick up
the amount you just put in if your
health Falls too low you'll be unable to
Sprint
I don't understand though like I have
half a leg
oh I can see
I can move a little bit
doc what's wrong with me
doc
oh
you leave me over here
I can't
say nothing
oh oh
[__]
anyways it got a growth on his head
do something
so Noir
okay so I'm
stupid injured
more than a dozen mutilated bodies found
in the village of Elk River several
residents unaccounted for
in the Crimson post
it's spelled with a k
to give me
hello anybody there
friendly enough
is everyone else all right the city
whatever are you talking
the bugs are gone
where's that lady
Hospital
this place is necessary for you
you're always welcome here I've been
hospitalized I'm afraid I cannot answer
that
please sign in here
without signing in
what was she gonna say there is no way
to ensure your future memories
this way please
I probably should have signed
I didn't sign it
should I sign it I'll sign it all right
accept
not not because I chose not to it wasn't
gonna let me save
can I turn this on
no
I thought a little music would lighten
the mood
I'm not a big fan of grandson it looks
like medicine
grandfather clocks make gross noises at
night and they scare me
I don't have a
ction
am I walking over medicine
no
just reminding me of my health
you are all right please relax
Liars
have a seat no
you're insane
you're a ghost I can see right through
you
all right I'll sit down
what the hell oh
you mustn't fight it I really shouldn't
look at the chat when important stuff's
happening no
green gel can be used to upgrade
individual skill parameters
there now you see all better
lady am I going crazy
well you're on fire
completely reasonable thing now oh I'm
on fire
you wanna pull anyone else out of there
[__] what the hell is going on
where am I
good man where are you
Connally
the origin of the medicine in this
travel syringe is unknown but it
provides moderate Health Restoration how
do you know that it's unknown
fine oh
so I can make it a shortcut
I will make it up
and I think I'm almost dead so I should
probably use it as well
um I'll use it
Lord I'm Healed
um did you guys see that latest Need for
Speed maybe it's pretty bad but
it's part where someone dies
see them kind of like
you know they're like super dead and
burning in the vehicle you're supposed
to pull them out
you can't
doctor
Leslie
are you in there
oh there's all sorts of goodies
okay
getting bonuses for
sleuthing around here
it's good
it's kind of
resident evil-esque you know they put
little bonuses in places because the
thing about these games are is they make
you so scared that you don't actually
want to investigate because you're
afraid you'll get super murdered
um
but then
if you investigate a little bit there's
a really good chance that you'll
you'll find a secret
that'll help you I'm too scared to go
that way
I'll stick with the top
this path of blood and guts
seems safer
I have no system to my logic is that
flash
oh Lord
you see that
no it's just like I keep feeling like
I'm seeing shiny things but I'm just
paranoid is all hell
pretty good actually
good enough oh
[__]
why
oh
is that a deer
there's all those goobles hanging out
do you think I can open this box
mitts
okay
God
what the [__] am I going
I can't see
all right let's use the light technique
we'll go back into the light and look
for the brightest spot
typically
if you head towards the light
you survive
right
a bonfire
praise the Sun
oh
crap
that dude's a zombo
can I
I was hoping if I held down it I could
you know like
I'm like really hype it up
you're gonna be eating someone
where's Leslie oh
foreign
did I shoot him
I actually don't know it happens so fast
die Connolly
God
and he was only one day to retirement
[__]
that took like
four bullets probably a few were in the
neck but still
look at that body physics
push them over and everything
green goo
is there any stuff in these boxes
it doesn't really look like it does it
so there's this cave
but then
that's it that's all there is
I thought there's two spots oh bullets
stop it I'll pick those up
honestly
in terms of cursing more of it's going
to come from
the controls it probably will from me
being cared but pisses me off
don't I want that Lantern
it won't let me pick it up
so
screw it
what do you guys think
all right
continue through the cave
I'm not oh it's in my butt I thought I
didn't have it
a trolley
I'll punch that trolley
nope I missed
I don't know if it wants to be punched
kind of
this can be punched I know when things
can be punched
wrong
oh [__] I'm highlight oh no
I really think
it stands to reason that this trolley
should be used
with that fence right
I'll try punching it again
there's also this
this guy go down there
oh it's Leslie
hurts hurts whoa
were you warning me about this
you were Leslie right
I'm a police officer
maybe I should help you should help you
[__]
how am I gonna get you to a hospital
hospital
what the [__] yeah I feel the same way
disarming traps
hold a to disarm them
can I just duck under it
you think that'll catch me
do you think I can limbo it
yeah I got it
I got that [__]
Leslie
say hospital if you're okay
oh
left bumper
oh I love sprinting
that's my favorite thing
and Sprint
I get tired already yeah
approach a fallen enemy and press B to
burn them destroying them completely
burning consumes one match if the same
enemies are close enough they can all be
burned with one match other things
besides corpses and enemies can also be
burned
so
it didn't really explain that I needed
to burn them though
like why like will he rise from the dead
because nothing's technically risen from
the dead yet
right oh green goo
better safe than sorry when burning the
Dead
the Oink
I want that box
I don't need that Lantern
in that box
nothing
not tease
yeah I hear crows
cha
that was a test
it was a quick draw test
yeah see
I feel like I could have burnt this hay
and that would have also been a really
good decision but I'm out of matches
so I actually can't burn that
and I I'd like to press how much I
really want to burn them
who wants to go in here
balls
get green goo
smash box that doesn't understand
um
Journal
finally I got my gold badge
I like the sound of that seems like a
long time coming but they say that I'm
one of the fastest ever to rise the Rex
I can't wait to get started I know that
I can do good as a detective more good
than I ever could as a beat cup plus
don't have to wear that damn uniform
anymore
the pay bump doesn't hurt either
KCPD needs all the help they can get
there's a seemingly disproportionate
amount of crime these days Crimson city
is my home it's my job to protect it
generic cop journal entry
number one
[__]
I'll bite what's in there
back here again in the hospital again
I must be losing it
I wonder when they use classical music
if
slightly it's because that music's free
I don't know if that was about him or
this is
whatever is the matter
hmm
foreign
technically I should be done but I think
I'm Gonna Keep playing
um as long as you guys
are
still interested
think I'll just keep going
yes he is tripping balls someone said
that
they all upgrade some stuff in this
chair of Fire
how am I supposed
does that take me back
because I kind of want to upgrade before
I do that
I don't think I'm fully aware of how the
mirror holes work yet
I'm gonna
upgrade first and then I'll use the
mirror hole
all right what do you guys think
abilities
weapons or stock I'm gonna tell you
right now I actually don't think that
weapons is going to help me super like
super much because
I think they're going to limit how much
ammo I get severely in this game and I I
actually don't think that it's going to
help a lot
so thinking about going with abilities
although I'm not really sure
what even the abilities are but I'm
gonna try that
see what they get
life gauge I can have a little bit more
health
Sprint time three seconds
oh plus three seconds I would assume
it's not very much melee damage that
would be pretty helpful because
I mean right now I like
I feel like that's all I have besides my
gun with what four bullets in it and
syringe recovery health recovered from a
syringe is increased well that's pretty
good too
that's a tough one
have a feeling
that just having a little bit extra
health will really help but I can't
afford it oh I can't afford any of the
[__] in case you guys wanted any of it
so
tough nuggets
check stock
I could always save I could save
um increasing amount of Handgun
Ammunition I feel like I'm gonna use it
like I'll probably shoot people
so I don't know how important that is
crazy a number syringes that can be
carried right now I can carry
two and I would be able to carry three
and increase the number of matches so
I would be seven matches that's pretty
good and then let's quickly check out
weapons because we're already here I
don't know [__] damage multiple plier
fire rate
reload time I bet you that's pretty
effing helpful honestly
just to quickly have your stuff together
and accuracy would be really good as
well actually
oh crit
uh 10 of killing an enemy instantly
it's pretty good but it's only 10 so
it's not very high all right let's do
accuracy I think that's pretty helpful
[__] and
reload time is pretty helpful but I
think I'm actually gonna
save
the rest of it
so that I can save it up
because I think it'll be really good
when I get some more green goo
to upgrade
my health which I I really would like to
do
a whole
and now I am in the game again
beautiful
all right
I feel like
is there anything over here why is there
this fence anyway
I don't think there's anything over here
I just thought it was well lit
and if it's lit
if it's lits I said
because
that's how games work
oh yeah I can Sprint I forgot
sprinty this way
look how [__] my Sprint is
and then after I Sprint I choke for a
little bit
I don't see how that's helpful at all
he's knocking that guy's door down
should I save him
oh
I'm technically in these weeds
right bumper plus a is a sneak kill and
I can kill enemies from behind
see that's the stuff that's why I think
that melee would be good
where are you going dude
see
I knew it
kind of hoping I can get him to attack
that door again
what is that
I think those are guts
let's try
oh he's gonna find me
oh what an idiot
oh
he [__] bit the [__] out of me
suck you
oh he killed me
damn
I have no health
ah
well I'm disappointed in myself
damn
I think this is
no I don't want to save I thought that
was loading cancel
so the last time
I was here
it was before I got in this chair right
so I actually haven't done
yeah because I have 1800 which is just
enough to not
get more health
which really sucks
and melee damage is two thousand
fudge all right I'm gonna save it
I'm gonna save all my money so that I
can get
higher melee and higher life which I
think is more valuable
it didn't do a today
probably hit Y
all right we'll try this again
I get tired so easily
thank you
[__]
yeah that worked out way better
I thought there was somebody in here
oh there he is
climb over obstacles and through windows
yeah I agree this isn't so much of a
horror game as it is like a creepy game
so far but I I've also heard rumors
my Lantern doesn't have a shadow
just looks like I'm hanging out
um
I heard that it is fairly gory
so I don't I don't know
kind of with you on what
what it is but currently it's just a
creepy game
a creepy
resi evil
y
game
hello
I feel like my Lantern makes me
not sleuthy
at all
Leslie
some other guy
hey are you guys from around here I
don't know where
okay
oh
gross
that's so gross
turn off your Lantern idiot
oh he's [__] super Sammy
I have one of still oh [__] these I hate
you oh crap just run
[__] you guys
they're probably way faster than me
oh I can't run because I'm hurt
oh crap that guy's gonna stupid kill me
you think he sees me
bastard
I'm so almost dead do I have any health
left
nope
do you think I should go back and kill
that other guy because there might be
health over there but the problem is is
he'll probably kill me
because like that house looks really
really enticing
it down you idiot
like I feel like
if I could just kill that guy
that house would be have something good
in it
I'm basing this off of nothing
go
please don't turn around
that's right
in your Dome
now as long as only good things are in
here I'll be fine
green goo
I can get my health upgrade
sucks I have all this progress but
literally if anything touches me I'm
going to die
do you think I should burn that woman
that's in the ground she's probably
should will it burn the house
all right let me just get this [__] real
fast
I thought I
huh
um
thought I moved my health syringe to the
top but I guess because I used it it
took it away
um
so I need to be able to use it again
so how do I use that syringe that I just
got
I'll burn this [__] and then I'll think
about it
also should I check closets
oh is this to hide
I don't really need to hide
oh
no I don't think there's anything else
in here
sucks like I basically get one match in
every instance but it would have been
really nice to have a few because
yeah I'd like to kill that dude I'd like
to
like to move his body
I know this isn't
very exciting
what they locked it I just came through
there I was gonna say it would have been
would have been really nice to just
save it real fast
but I can't
so I won't
so there's that dude up there he looks
great
it's over here
walk to the end
it's a beautiful night
oh man this is so creepy
I'm like I'm being
looking at it
again with the lights
you just know you're going there one
time
it's beautiful
kind of feel like I'm in a
Friday the 13th movie
there's something about docs and Jason
Voorhees
well I'm definitely
creeped out we didn't say I've like
been scared crapless yet but it's
definitely
still possible
how big do you think their site cones
are do you think I can
cross over here and he won't notice me
I'm in the weeds
look how almost dead I am
and if I die I'm gonna have to redo I
think that thing I just did because I
haven't gotten to a safe plan
all right
I feel like he's looking right the F at
me
I don't even know where to make them go
maybe over there
what
[__] stupid
there he goes it's just the latest [__]
climb
that didn't work that didn't work that
didn't work
it didn't work it didn't work it didn't
work
I have like no time to sneak up
[__]
I really need to do that house thing
again because I need that
did it save
D I don't even
foreign
yeah I'm like
not sure if that saved or not that
really sucks
hello
one bullet
well thanks a lot
I'll take that bottle
was there other stuff I didn't see I
feel like
this game is probably
just covered in secrets
she got to be
constantly looking to see everything
oh
I see you
oh oh
come on you idiot
oh he's glitched
[__] idiot
look at him he's in the fence
good job you [__]
that's the secret I just need to contain
them all within fences
oh I could burn this hay
I'm not entirely sure why I'd want to do
that though
is that the front of him or the back of
him one of the problems with how zombie
they are is that it's actually really
hard to tell
what it is your
you're looking at
like where the hell is this face
okay oh
can you see me right now
back up back up back up back up back up
back up
I really want to kill that guy
all right
yeah I'll let you in there oh wait that
still took a match
but I was carrying this
why the hell would that take a match I
have a torch in my hand I'm literally
holding fire
torch is pretty helpful considering I
can't burn anything with it
I think I'm supposed to hide in there
oh that was awesome
that was really enjoyable
I think I was just oh green goo
yoink
yeah it definitely didn't save
that sucks
that's all right
time don't dice
stupid
I'm really glad that thing popped up
because I would have walked right into
that bear trap
because I I wasn't paying attention
was it right
I have no other weapons besides this
I'm almost dead how did it say to disarm
a bear trap I wasn't really paying
attention
was it right bumper
nope
I'm gonna die
sound right well I'm not gonna try
when the bear traps come I'll know
sneak plus a that's all right
well I'm almost dead again
specifically because of bear traps
and my own genius
I can hear him
but I can't see him
I see a trap here too
where is it
I feel like I really give myself away
when I do that
oh yeah
yeah is that diet
you know I like the real thing
co-workers kindly giving me soda to keep
me alive
thanks
oh get out
will he follow me well he sure as [__]
well
where's the Trap where's the Trap
can I make
I'm over here stupid
all that effort
thank you
I know he's
oh there's a bear trap right there
where'd that guy go
you go back in through the window
well it looks like there's all sorts of
ways
you know you can go about this
but
let's go in through the front of the
house
this is like Home Alone
zombies
hey
you
s o s
this [__] idiot
they never notice me when I want them to
I have like very little life so I have
to do this pretty cautiously
unfortunate line
oh [__]
come on right here
yay
that's so oh
did you hear that noise it made it was a
little like
could really use a mirror hole right now
yeah
I think there's some
can I get up there
doesn't want me to
all right well there's some green goo in
here we'll get that
and then I guess I'll just keep going
kind of seems like this is
what we're looking at in terms of
gameplay is
not so much
shooting but more
stealthfully getting things to hit
tripwires which personally
I really enjoyed getting him to to kill
himself like that
it's very
enjoyable Sarah I thought there was a
dude over here
bucket run
oh
hey
yeah backpack backpack
oh there's another one
there's a bear trap over here
oh crap
I'm gonna die
I might have to use my
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
I can hear him
go you
can
hurt bastard
hooray a save point
we did it
I really thought that bear trap would
kill him but it looks like it just maims
them terribly
come on go in there it's all well lit
you see that
good God
that's right just keep doing what you're
doing oh
good
where are the bear traps when you need
them
oh my effing Lord
I can't run because I'm too hurt
so
this is my plan
it's going pretty well
foreign
well no [__]
God damn it God damn it
oh
I'm badass
jump into the river
that better not actually cost me one of
my photos
thank you
save save
except
pretty fun having a good time
next chapter where are we at here we'll
go a little further
shoot explosive bolts on the ground or
walls to place mine traps that enemies
can set off
that's pretty cool that I can set off
traps
or that I can actually set traps not
just set them off
hitting an enemy with a torch can burn
them to death in one hit
well I should have paid attention to
that
all right
the torch seems way more useful now
can I
feel like I could have just opened that
nothing
Zippo
claws of The Horde that sounds
I'll take you
I'll take you oh I'm at three
why can't I
get on that boat
I would like to get on this boat
no
no boat
doesn't look very safe
fair enough
well I feel like I don't have a lot of
Health
ah
what was that noise
I hear like wolves or some [__]
grass
those people burned up so fast
like they're made out of
lighter fluids
well that was convenient
[__] no go backsies
I'll reload it actually I think about it
considering my reload time is
lighter the um Lantern doesn't really
help but it's not very dark here anyway
can I get up there
do you want to
oh
I only have three matches I need to
conserve
how do I
I think I need to
put stuff in there again but I can't
remember how
so I have two
and I will use one
I'm so healthy
and I think I lost my
lighter unfortunately my torch would
have been nice
no
oh those are kegs
I know that noise you guys know that
noise
that means
that means mirror hole
just to give you guys a brief update
my name's Mary I've been playing The
Evil Within now for what hour and a half
hour 45 minutes it's my first time
playing it I've never picked up the game
touched it before today uh or hurt
really even seen any gameplay videos or
anything I've seen the trailers pretty
good so far it's pretty creepy it's more
creepy and it really reminds me of like
more of just a Resident Evil type game
more than like a jump scare Style game
and I really like it
um
first day as a detective the story is
interesting it's very like generic cop
story a new partner Myra Hanson is a
real firecracker this is a great opening
sentence tenacious and No Nonsense my
kind of woman but I gotta watch it
around her she almost caught me checking
out her ass today
there's a technique for that
girls do it too we're just way so sure
about it
it's interesting that it starts here
kind of
I haven't investigated anything else
around here
I wonder where that takes me
I can't go in anything else so there is
that forgotten something
there is that hole at the end of the
hallway I can check that baby out
but first
I'ma buy all right I'm so at a loss for
what I really want to buy because
there's so many things I want to buy and
I don't have nearly enough green goo
but I
I do think melee damage is incredibly
helpful because I've been mailing people
so poorly
so I think I'm gonna buy that and I
think I'm gonna use it way more
um and then what else
uh
um
I really need I I haven't maxed out my
ammo but I I might this time
so hard to know what I should be
spending my money on right now these are
the types of decisions that on my second
playthrough
I would really understand
much more
um what the benefits are of what I'm
doing like right now I have I have no
idea
perfect
all right I don't think I should have
done that again but that's okay
I already did it I've committed I'm not
going back no take backsies
just want to save
accept
all right let's see what this guy does
probably nothing exciting
and I'm going to test it let's see if
this mirror takes me anywhere else
Danny don't scare me
none of my co-workers have tried to
scare me I'm really surprised
because I would 100 expect them to
because they're jerks
yeah this is just where I was
no big surprise
okay
I heard the beeps and I did nothing
I'm so hurt
I
ah
that's hilarious
oh
let's go back in time
laughs
like anyone else who probably plays with
a hero
run and I stood there
in case
uh
um
[__] [__]
oh well oh
it's Connolly
that dude I murdered
all right
no did I not hold it long enough let's
try it again
really gotta commit all right so there's
a booby trap
right here
there was no sound effect did you see
that
foreign
I'm not really sure
okay
well I should probably go upstairs but
I'll have to be really [__] fast
about it right
huh
I didn't make it I was the best you know
now I'm almost dead again this is
becoming
over here
no
oh
I can't believe
it's such a cool hiding spot
do you think they're gonna come up here
I thought I heard
people saying like over here
who's there no don't shoot I'm not one
of them I'm a doctor Marcelo Jimenez you
were in the ambulance before a crash
right yes we're lucky to be alive have
you seen anyone else my patient Leslie I
saw him running up ahead but but come
this way
quietly mind you
Leslie
have a look for yourself
things
to me all the way
we hit me too
they're all over the place
Leslie went through that gate
good Lord
there are too many to shoot our way
through
one of us could try to lure them away
while the other gets the gate open
you're the one with the gun
if you say so
a doctor's kind of a
[__]
ah damn Gumball the thing there's a
crank on the Terrace
shut up
I'm looking for secrets
stupid
but
I never really liked that doctor
foreign
I hate that the door shuts behind you
is that a secret hiding spot cool I like
that there's little hidey holes
everywhere
can I hide under that bed too so that's
pretty neat
oh
basement
can I have that hatchet
good job
why would I choose a bottle over a
hatchet
I feel like I should do what that doctor
says I was just curious of what was
going on in the rest of the house
but now I will do as the doc says
I will let him
down
I think it's through here
even though he's kind of a jerk
I'm confused over here here
hey over here that's right this way
oh my problem
all right
well
I'm gonna keep going through this house
but it looks like
gotten ourselves
pretty deep into the game now it looks
like like the meat of the game is
starting to show here
that guy beat the crap out of me oh
do you guys see that [__]
oh my
God
we get in there
all right
it was a pretty good place to stop for
now scare the crap out of me
I didn't think they could be behind me
well
all right we'll we'll kind of stop it
there for now this is
I mean currently it's freaking really
fun I think
um there's a lot more to see I basically
barely even scratch the surface
of
probably the combat system I I know that
you get a shotgun later on and several
other types of firearms which I'd really
like to try out I really barely got to
see I really barely got to see anything
I'm looking the wrong way
um but from what I did see it kind of
feels like
it's a really enjoyable game and it's
really good at driving up tension of
making you feel like you're never safe
and
it reminds me of those old feelings of
playing res evil which I really like of
the good ones
so uh I definitely will be playing this
more uh to get a little bit further into
it and see where I find but hopefully
you guys enjoyed watching me get scared
and enjoyed what you saw so far of The
Evil Within so we should be playing some
more games like this I believe
um we'll be doing another now playing on
Friday
uh and then again we'll probably uh
maybe even bring this up on the lobby
next Tuesday at 2PM so definitely check
back to Gamespot for more playing of
games and thanks for watching you guys
I'll see you later